je reconnais plus la france parce que on
a réussi enfin il ce gouvernement a
réussi à diviser un français qui se
parlaient a maintenant deux françaises
font la guerre parce que toi tu es le
bon parce que thé vaccinés toi tu es le
mauvais parce qu'à cause de non mais
c'est pas le gouverneur alors là c'était
ton tous les pays du monde aurions nous
ça va ya 90 ans alors je vais vous dire
les autres pays du monde je m'en
contrefous alors j'ai de regarder ce qui
se passe en
amont des deux fuites at il dit liberté
égalité fraternité on me dit que la
france est championne du monde d'impôt
personnes payent plus d'impôts que nous
dans le monde on ferme des lits on me
dit qu'on est ouvert au monde on me dit
que les tous les réfugiés faut les
accueillir et j'en suis fier je paye des
impôts j'en suis fier la carte vitale
j'en suis fier à thé de parler de
l'estonie arrêter de me parler de la
norvège arrêtez de parler de lyme
l'allemagne où il roule à 200 sur les
routes on comprend que ce qui nous
arrange moi je vais vous expliquer une
chose je veux pas rentrer dans une loi
je veux pas rentrer dans un système où
bernard pour une entrecôte au café père
m'a demandé ma pièce d'identité vous
rendez compte qu'il va se passer là dit
rien mais mais si tu sors je donnais pas
commencé tous des menteurs le patinage
va vous emmener à donner une pièce
d'identité à berne a recommandé c'est ça
moi je vais te laisser finir si on
habite je veux pas que le médecin h
comment je m'appelle où j'habite quand
est-ce que je suis né qu'elle nationale
et quand tu fais un shark d'ivoire est
intelligente ça les arrange pas et qu'on
ait une journée s'achève au dessus fait
par l'administration est d'avoir le feu
vert
de l'administration je m'en fous donner
ma pièce d'identité et au delà de ça
vous allez voir ce qui va se passer moi
la police j'ai toujours respecté quand
la police est bien boire assermentés tu
vas retaper entité je la donne
maintenant que je vais la donner à
bernard le boucher à isabelle à la
piscine le policier quand il va me
donner ça ne monte pas plus que bernard
vous êtes en train de détruire vous êtes
en train de détourner l'attention mais
quoi mais non mais sérieux vous voudrez
vous déconner mais les mecs vous rendez
compte que vous êtes vous fait
désactiver moi je suis pour le vaccin
vous mais je suis pas contre le passage
suis contre eux passent à l'étape pas
axa désactiver à distance certes y'a un
mec qui va dire tu arrivé de voir ce
taux je te désactive allez hop après
c'est une désactive quad on t'a précieux
qui vêtu désactive
là il a une date limite têtu et
françois jolivet quand vous entendez
révolte il ya deux ans vous avez des
singes possible on vaccinera way
toi les horizons baba sur youtube mais
non pas en france en france jamet
liberté égalité fraternité bête que tu
étais
déjà dit il habite en estonie
moi très calmement je vais dire à
monsieur moi je suis très énervé parce
que ça m'énerve
je respecte vos propos je sais que votre
analyse mais on peut avoir des points d
accord et un shérif d'henry les répare
le départ le vaccin on est d'accord je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les pouvoirs
publics essaye de tout mettre en oeuvre
parce que derrière les élus y ait aussi
des administrations qui travaillent
l'administration du ministère de la
santé notamment et je pense que tout le
monde a envie de bien faire son travail
et il ya des remontées d'informations
qui sont faites également par les
hôpitaux
et qu'on vous dit que c'est une atteinte
à la liberté de montrer un pass
sanitaire qui deviendra vaccinale en
fait c'est vrai qu'il sanctionne que les
gens qui n'ont qui avant ce prêt pouvait
entraîner déjà à 40 euros pouvaient
entrer avec un test pcr aujourd'hui
c'était plus possible parce que
l'objectif et les amener à la
vaccination moi je serais je reprendrai
les oreilles
pourquoi
aujourd'hui
monsieur
j'ai signé une tribune qui est dans le
coiffage et qu il fit une tribu moi je
pense que la prochaine étape derrière
parce anitea presse vaccinale c'est le
cap doit être la vaccination obligatoire
moi je voudrais vous interroger tout de
même et je voudrais on parlera bientôt à
sa soeur contours d'un professeur
pourquoi est-ce qui a pas eu d'atteinte
à la liberté quand on a imposé les onze
vaccin parce qu'ils sont jamais assez le
monsieur mais terminé vous rendez vous
êtes en train de parler un chauffeur
sont en phase expérimentale elle est
finie non mais les eaux des mois les
11500 la phase expérimentale sur le sont
pas oui chauffeur livreur est en train
de vous expliquer ça mais bien sûr que
c'est un monde et où là non
[Applaudissements]